تفشي مرض جدري القردة المتزايد في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، يراقب مركز السيطرة على
الأمراض عن كثب مجموعة من ستة أشخاص بحثًا عن إصابات محتملة ، حيث يعمل
مسؤولو الصحة والرئيس
بايدن على تخفيف المخاوف المتزايدة بشأن
الفيروس ، ولا أعتقد أنه يزيد
من مستوى القلق من أن
كانت موجودة
مع covet 19 أو
ولقاح الثعلب الصغير يعمل من أجله ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه يجب على الناس توخي الحذر
وتقول منظمة الصحة العالمية إن هناك
أكثر من 90 حالة مؤكدة في عشرات
البلدان حيث لا يتوطن جدري القردة
بالفعل ، ويوجد المرض في
الغالب في  غرب ووسط أفريقيا ، لكن مركز
السيطرة على الأمراض يقول إنه قلق من
العدد المتزايد للحالات المبلغ عنها خارج تلك
المناطق يوم الأحد ،
قال منسق استجابة البيت الأبيض في 19 إنه
يمكن أن يكون هناك المزيد من الحالات ، لكنه لا يتوقع أن يكون لجدري القردة
تأثير واسع النطاق في الولايات
المتحدة.  إنه ليس معديًا مثل مرض كوفيد ، لذا
أنا واثق من أننا سنكون قادرين على
الحفاظ على أذرعنا حوله ،
فقد أمرت الحكومة الأمريكية بمبلغ 119 مليون
دولار  لقاحات ضد
فيروس جدري القرود هذا مرتبط بالجدري
ولكن الأعراض الأقل فتكًا تشمل الحمى
والقشعريرة.ضعف العضلات
وتورم الغدد الليمفاوية والآفات والطفح الجلدي
على الجسم ينتشر في الغالب عن طريق الاتصال المباشر ،
لذا فإن ملامسته للسوائل
تلامسها من الأغطية التي تلامسها
من اليدين  إذا كان لدى شخص ما تلك
المطبات الكبيرة في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم ، فأنا جين
سوليفان